Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
No else.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This episode is brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the people I've interviewed,
world class performers across the military,
entertainment,
sports and beyond all have some type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help you.
This change comes through guided meditation and headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple,
so what I recommend is that you take this practice meditation which is rooted in
thousands of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of scientific studies and try it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the founder Andy Puddicombe,
a Ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is Pud,
d I.
If you want to look that up,
but otherwise,
download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation.
Completely free.
10 minutes a day.
That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just go to headspace.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive,
in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is,
why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
And here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with.
Like automatic tax loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show is because I use them and recommend
them.
In this case it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials,
so I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account,
but just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim,
it's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Greetings,
earthlings.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is always,
or I should say usually my job to deconstruct world class performers,
to tease out the habits,
routines,
tools,
favorite practices,
workouts,
books,
whatever it might be that they use that you can test,
that you can experiment with in your own life.
And this episode is going to be a round two highly anticipated with none other
than Jocko Willink.
And Jocko did his first interview with me,
which was the first interview we ever did and it took the Internet by storm
Jocko Willink.
Jocko Willink on Twitter.
Jocko podcast.com is one of the scariest human beings imaginable.
Lean 230 pounds black belt Brazilian Jujitsu,
used to tap out 20 navy seals per workout.
He is an intimidating and very intelligent person.
I've spent more time with him,
uh,
and the more time that I spend with him,
the more impressive he is to me.
He spent 20 years in the US Navy and commanded seal team three is tasking at
bruiser of the most highly decorated special operations unit from the Iraq war.
Upon returning to the u s Jocko served as the officer in charge of training for
all west coast seal teams,
designing and implementing some of the most challenging and realistic and
perhaps psychotic combat training in the world.
His words,
not mine.
After retiring from the navy,
he cofounded echelon front.
I think I'm getting the pronunciation right.
Leadership and Management Consulting Company and authored the Number One New
York Times best seller which was introduced in way on my podcast,
extreme ownership which many of you have read.
He now discusses war leadership,
business,
Jujitsu life,
you name it in his top rated podcast.
Also to some really,
really good book reviews or commentary on things that are dark and some cases
like the my Lai massacre,
Jocko podcasts.
Check it out and without further ado we are going to tackle or I should say
Jocko is going to tackle your most common,
most burning questions and he doesn't dodge so I hope you enjoy it as much as I
did Jocko Willink.
A thanks Tim.
Thanks for having me on.
Appreciate it and thanks to everybody that submitted questions.
I'm going to try and get to as many as I can here.
All right.
The first one is from a guy by the name of Jeffrey McCloud and the question is
how do you shut internal doubt down and negative chatter out of your head during
critical must do moments?
How do you change emotional negative focus states when something or someone
knocks you off?
Focus.
First of all,
internal doubt is not necessarily a bad thing.
And I've said this before about fear of failure because internal doubt that
first of all,
that's a form of humility and obviously humility is a good thing and that
internal doubt and that fear of failure is the thing that the thing that keeps
you up at night preparing,
that's the thing that's not going to let you cut corner.
It's the thing
is that little voice,
that little voice inside your head that's whispering,
rehearse again,
practice again,
do it again over and over again.
And that's the voice that says to do everything you can
to be ready.
So I'm,
I'm okay with that.
I'm okay with that little internal doubt.
But this doesn't mean that you lack confidence.
I mean,
as a matter of fact,
when you,
when you prepare correctly,
when you have the discipline to prepare correctly,
then you will have confidence and that is definitely a,
a good feeling to have because
all that negative chatter that you're talking about here,
here's the deal with that.
Every repetition of practice that you do,
every iteration of rehearsal that you complete,
every bit of study that you do and every drill that you do,
all that,
all that preparation is going to drown out the,
the negative chatter.
So you got to prepare now,
then we get to this piece.
Here it was how do you change emotional negative focus states when something or
someone knocks you off focus?
Well,
I think this is where it's important to have that ability to detach and
it isn't like you're going to completely detach and not feel those things at
all.
Not like you're gonna make those emotions disappear and it's not even like you'd
want them to disappear completely because those things are normal.
But what you have to do when you detach is it's going to allow you to,
to see those emotions or that negative focus and see it from a distance and then
understand that they are there and then make sure that they don't overwhelm you.
And so like in your head you're going to be saying,
oh,
okay,
I see that.
That's,
that's some nervousness sneaking up on me.
Got It.
That's a good sign because that means my mind is focused and I'm in the game.
Okay,
what's next?
Oh,
oh,
got some some negative thoughts.
Okay,
well those are normal and I got to know that things are going to go bad and
that's fine.
How bad can they go?
What's a worst case scenario
and worst case scenario is not that big of a deal.
I know I can handle the worst case scenario if it happens.
So what else?
What else is in my mind?
What else negative thought am I having?
What about those things that you can't control?
The things that you can't control and you're worried about those things.
Well,
you know what?
I can't control them though.
If I can't control them,
why worry about them?
Because the energy that you put into worrying about them actually cost you your
effectiveness.
It's going to cut into the energy you should be putting towards achieving what
you're trying to achieve.
So focus on the things that you can control and make the things that you can
control 100% and the bottom line with all of this,
with these negative thoughts.
If,
if I give everything I can,
if I prepare as hard as I can,
if I practice as much as I can.
If I do have a rehearsal and I do everything I can and I still come up short,
good,
I'm going to learn from it.
I'm going to get better.
So that's what I'm going to do with internal doubt.
I'm okay with it.
Negative chatter,
I'm going to utilize it and I'm just going to detach a little bit
to make sure I don't get drowned out in these emotional situations.
So just get your head in the game and get after it
done.
Okay,
next question.
Next question comes from we'll,
we'll again drawn
and he says,
how does his love of
love and study of literature influences leadership skills?
What were some of the best books for developing his knowledge of leadership?
Okay,
so the thing that I look for when I'm reading and when I'm reading that includes
everything and let's just talk about everything here.
Books,
history,
books,
literature,
even poetry and even like song lyrics,
everything.
I'm trying to learn about human nature.
That's what I'm looking for.
[inaudible] and of course since since combat is like life amplitude amplified
and intensified,
which is something we say all the time,
a lot of times the books that are about war give some of the best insight into
human nature.
You know,
you're talking about the stress and the fear and the courage and the breaking
points and the darkness of humanity
and also
the beauty of humanity and all those can be seen in their most extreme and in
their most obvious form in war.
And so a lot of books that I do read are about war and I have a ton of them.
And again,
they're not so much leadership books by definition,
as matter of fact,
I don't even know if I have any quote unquote leadership books,
but I got a ton of books that have taught me a ton about leadership.
And first and foremost,
and I said this on when I was on Tim's podcast for the first time about face by
Colonel David Hackworth.
It's,
it's the only book of I've ever actually given to anyone.
And it's a big book that people,
people that have bought it,
people on Twitter that have gone out and bought that book.
It's a 700 page book.
It is a big book.
It spans from the tail end of World War II through Korea,
Vietnam,
and a little bit of post Vietnam.
And it's a big book.
It's a career military guy.
And Colonel Hackworth was just,
just a,
just an incredible leader.
And you don't just get from the that from the book when you,
when you learned about Hackworth,
if you start digging in and,
and hearing what other people's opinions are,
people loved him,
especially the people that worked for him,
loved him.
Now obviously had some trouble up the chain of command at certain points.
But that's,
that's part of being that,
that's part of being a dynamic leader I guess.
And he held his ground on some stuff.
So that book is just incredible book and it's got lessons learned on every page.
And you know,
I covered most of the books that I've read that have had a huge impact on me.
I'm like,
I'm covering them on my podcast.
So books like,
like a with the old breed by Eugene sled sledge and beyond band of brothers by
Dick Winters.
I remember the last war by a guy named Bob Hoffman,
another book by Hackworth called steal my soldier's heart
book called platoon leader by Jim Mcdonough and another good one,
another good Vietnam one,
the killing zone by Frederick downs in
those books.
I mean you could just go on and on and again,
it's not always clear that,
oh,
here's the leadership principle,
here's what you should be doing.
No,
it's not always clear like that.
But when you,
when you understand what people are going through emotionally and you start to
get a glimpse at human nature and how people react in certain situations and how
their egos flare up,
that's what makes these books good because it gives you something to,
as it gives you a frame of reference and I'm still reading all the time and I'm
still learning,
still trying to get better and still trying to take what other people been
through,
how they handled it,
what they did right,
what they did wrong,
mistakes they made.
That's what I'm trying to do.
And actually I think that's actually one of the things that has made my,
my podcast become popular is because I look at these other people's experiences
and I compare him with mine and it's just,
it's,
it's always,
I'm always learning.
And I think that when you look at,
I talk about the mistakes that I made and even even the book that I wrote with
leaf is it certainly isn't any kind of a chronicling of our triumphs.
I mean if anything it's the opposite in many cases.
Cause all much of the book is,
is about mistakes that we made.
And it's about things that we could've done better and lessons that we've
learned.
And I think that's why I think that's why it's why that book extreme ownership
has done well because it's something you can learn from.
And,
and I think people learn the most,
myself included when you fail.
So
read and read and read some more and pay attention to,
in my mind,
paypal,
pay attention to the details.
Not Again,
not just the leadership,
but the human,
the human element,
the human interaction,
the glimpses into the core of human nature in a bigger bank you build of
experiencing how humans react the more you know.
And then you take that and you overlay the experiences you read about over
what's happening in your world.
And that's it.
I think a key point is to actually think about how what you're reading applies
to what's happening in your world.
And then you start to pay attention to human nature and your world and see that
there's some underlying,
some underlying force that makes people do what they do.
And the better you can understand that force of human nature,
the better off you're going to be and the better job you're going to do as a
leader
to keep reading.
Next up,
I got a guy here named Kip Maca Nuni.
What would his advice be to young men and women who are no longer in the
military but are still looking to contribute?
Also,
has he considered running for any public office position?
So if,
if you were in the military and you got out,
either you retired or you just did your time and you got out,
you know,
go out and put those skills that you got from the military.
Put those skills to work with uh,
the discipline,
the work ethic,
the leadership,
the ability to attach,
to detach,
the ability to,
to instruct.
And there are industries,
I'm telling you,
I work with businesses all the time now and there are industries that need you.
In fact,
I will tell you that most industries need people like you,
people like veterans.
And so find an industry that,
that you're interested in and,
and go get busy and go get after it.
And make that your next mission.
And
if there's no industries that industry interests you,
which is kind of hard to believe that you would have no interest.
But if you don't,
or if you're looking for something maybe that has more kind of internal meaning,
then go out and find a really good nonprofit organization that needs help
because again,
they need the same thing.
They need people,
they need leaders,
they need people that are disciplined,
they need people that can solve problems,
they need people with the skills that you have,
the skills that you learned in the military.
So go and put those to work.
And I will tell you that
there's,
you know,
America as a whole needs leadership.
And so there's no reason that veterans,
like I said,
who,
who have a lot of those skills from being in the military and from being
deployed overseas,
there's no reason that veteran shouldn't make up a big portion of leaders in the
civilian sector.
So step up and get after.
And I'll say one last thing about that is there's a lot of companies,
and I work again,
I work with all kinds of different companies.
All kinds of companies want to hire veterans.
They,
they recognize that their success is based on the freedoms that they have.
So they want to pay back somehow.
And so there's many,
many companies are,
are anxious and eager to,
to hire veterans.
So get out there,
find what you're interested in and make it happen.
Now the other part of this question,
as far as running for political office,
and I say this all the time,
this is kind of a canned answer.
I don't think I have the stomach for it.
Um,
the,
the corruption and the slimy penis of the whole thing.
Not to mention just the complete loss of privacy and the scheduling and the
whole meeting of people that I don't like and having to be civil to them all
thing.
It's,
it's,
like I said,
I don't,
I don't think I have the stomach for it.
And I mean,
I guess that
perhaps at some point that feeling could be overridden if things got bad enough.
You know,
I would definitely have a sense of duty in and I'm a very patriotic person and
if the nation truly needed me,
then of course I would serve.
But until that time I'm going to go ahead and just steer clear of any political
endeavors.
Okay.
The next question is from Adrian Marquez and it says any considerations
regarding being a pawn of the,
and he says industrial military conflicts and maybe he means military industrial
complex.
I'm not sure,
but we'll,
we'll go with it.
Um,
so again,
any considerations regarding being a pawn of the industrial military conflicts
to serve the economic interests of US corporations?
Would he do it all over again?
The next part of the question is what's next?
Make up another excuse.
Invade an African nation for resources.
So
of course when you are serving in the u s military,
you are,
you are serving,
at least you should be serving the interests of the United States of America.
Absolutely.
And embedded in those interests.
There are absolutely the economic interests of American corporations and
obviously the economic power of the United States is a key component of
America's power.
And influence in the world.
And so yeah,
when you are a military member you could be considered a pawn in the military
machine.
But the fact of the matter is I am,
I'm actually honored to have served as a so called pawn a pawn in that system.
And I will tell you this,
and I've said this before,
America is,
is far from perfect and we have committed some horrors in our history and even
today we make mistakes in the world.
But when you travel the world
and you see how much of the rest of the world lives,
how much they live in
disarray,
then you see the oppression and you see the poverty and you see the corruption
and you see the abject violations of basic human rights.
Then you realize how blessed or lucky or or maybe even spoiled,
we are to live in America and,
and just to start,
let's just start with,
let's start with potable tap water drinking water that we just in America,
we just have that here.
We haven't everywhere any home,
any apartment,
even the prisons.
You turn on the tap and you get good clean disease,
free drinking water,
and that is not the norm in the rest of the world.
And on top of that,
we have power,
got electricity going into just about every home.
That means just about every home has heat in the wintertime and they have air
conditioning in the summertime.
And let's just take it a little bit further than what about the access to the
Internet.
The access to the Internet here is widespread.
There's something like 70% of the adults in America have a smartphone,
70% so 70% so you can gain access to knowledge here unlike any other time in
human history
and our our health care system.
I know it's not perfect,
but I'll tell you what.
If you view our healthcare system from a third world hospital,
which often don't even have the simplest of medical gear,
you'd realize it might not be perfect,
but it's pretty damn good.
And then beyond that,
it's just like,
let's look at the food that's available,
nevermind starvation and malnutrition.
Our issue in America is actually too much food
and much of the world still has people literally starving to death.
And America offers an amazing opportunity to build and to create and to be what
you want to be and to be who you want to be on.
Unlike anywhere else in the world,
the ability to pursue happiness,
happiness
and,
and all those things,
all of it
is possible because of the unbridled individual freedom that America offers.
And you know what else?
It's also possible because of the industry,
because of the incredible corporations and businesses and individuals cause of
people that took advantage of that freedom and work their asses off to build
this nation.
So
to have been a pawn in that,
to have done my small share of work,
to allow this beacon of light and of hope and have freedom to continue.
I'm honored that I had the chance.
And would I do it all again?
You're damn right.
I would without question.
And then there's another piece to this question from Mr. Marquez.
It says,
what's next?
Make up another excuse.
Invade an African country or an African nation for resources.
Well,
luckily we have plenty of resources in our own nation and luckily for the rest
of the world we have used those resources over and over and over again.
Not to take,
but to give,
to give freedom to the slaves in our own country,
to defeat and destroy the brutal Nazi regime in Germany and free the people of
France and much of Europe.
We used our resources to defeat imperial Japan,
who is rampaging through Asia invading and enslaving people with no sign of
stopping.
We used our resources,
try and stop the spread of communism in Asia
and remember that when I'm talking about resources,
I'm not just talking about oil and steel and wood,
I'm talking about blood.
I'm talking about hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of thousands of American
men and women that gave their lives
in the cause of freedom.
And in w what?
What resources did we take when we paid with our blood,
we took nothing.
We took,
we took no resources from the Germans.
We helped them rebuild into an economic superpower.
We took no resources from the Japanese.
We help them rebuild into an economic superpower.
The Japanese and the Germans both have some of the highest standards of living
in the world.
We took nothing from Korea or Vietnam and we took nothing from Afghanistan and
even Iraq,
we took nothing
and we only gave,
and we continue to give.
In 2014 the u s government gave $43 billion in foreign aid,
and then there was another 25 billion on top of that from America,
from religious organizations and universities and colleges and private voluntary
organizations,
and even the big American corporations.
Now,
like I said,
that doesn't mean that America's perfect
far from it,
and our past is checkered
with horrible mistakes that we've made as a nation.
We've caused massive hardships and incredible suffering,
but we also evolved
and
we have become a benevolent nation of good nation.
And I know this because I saw it with my own two eyes.
I saw the people of Iraq who wanted freedom,
the tyranny of Saddam Hussein,
who then wanted protection from the violent terrorists,
extremists who cheered us in the streets when we killed and surgeons and who
wept when we left them.
And unfortunately who were murdered when we abandoned them because the politics
in our own country,
they wanted us in Iraq,
the people of Iraq,
the normal citizens,
they wanted our protection and they wanted our positivity
and they wanted freedom
like much of the world does.
And I was honored to have done my small part
to provide the opportunity for freedom around the world and to protect that
precious freedom,
which is
all too often taken for granted
here at home.
Now
the next question,
the next question is from someone named Don Ryan
and he says,
what's the hardest thing you've ever gone through and what do you foresee as the
toughest thing on the Horizon Elan door?
Well,
the hardest thing I've ever gone through is losing my men in combat.
And I say my men,
but they weren't my men.
They were my friends and they were my brothers.
And barring the loss of
many members of my direct family,
I don't think I'll ever have to endure anything is
soul crushing and devastating
as losing my friends and combat.
Next question.
This is from Nathan low.
What advice would you give an active duty navy seal or other military personnel
following the election if Hillary is elected or if Trump is elected?
Well,
the fact of the matter is either Hillary or Trump will be elected
and the seals
just like the rest of the military will do what the military always does and
what they are sworn to do.
And if you don't know what that is,
I wrote down here the oath of enlistment and I'll read it to you.
So you know what it's what it says.
It says,
I do solemnly swear that I will support and defend the constitution of the
United States against all enemies,
foreign and domestic,
that I will bear true faith and allegiance to the same and that I will obey the
orders of the president of the United States and the orders of the officers
appointed over me according to the regulations and the uniform code of military
justice.
So help me God.
So that's the,
that's the oath that you swear to when you join the military,
you're going to obey those orders.
Now there is a little bit of a caveat and that is in the uniform code of
Military Justice Article 92 cause it gets a little bit more specific.
The articles entitled failure to obey order or regulation,
any person subject to this chapter who number one violates or fails to obey any
lawful general order or regulation
to having knowledge of any other lawful order issued by any member of the armed
forces,
which it is.
His duty to obey fails to obey the order or is derelict and the performance of
his duties shall be punished as court martial may direct.
So the keyword there is lawful order and they made this perfectly clear during
the Nuremberg trials when the Nazi war criminals claim that they were just
following orders.
Well in America that doesn't cut it.
They have to be lawful orders.
So regardless if Hillary Clinton,
Donald Trump,
Obama,
Bush,
Nixon,
JFK or Reagan,
it doesn't matter.
The military will carry out the lawful orders of the president.
And that's that
next question is from a j Nystrom.
He says,
Jocko,
in your book you speak about leadership down and up the chain of command.
What in your opinion and experiences the most effective way to get leadership up
the chain to wake up and break the cycle of rubber stamping ineffective
practices,
especially in law enforcement.
So this is a big question and I'll tell you first things first.
The first thing you have to do is be awesome.
That's what you gotta do.
Seriously,
you got to be the best police officer you can be.
And this goes for any job you got to build the best possible reputation.
And that means you gotta follow the rules,
even the stupid inconsequential rules,
all of them become the front runner,
the top dog.
Now that doesn't mean you become the loud mouth or the attention grabber,
but you become the best legit police officer you can possibly be.
And not only is this going to build your reputation,
it's also going to start to build your relationships up the chain of command.
And that's what you're trying to do.
You're trying to build some relationships here.
And the reason for that is you need to build up the capital,
the leadership capital,
the respect capital so that you can ask some legitimate questions.
And when the time comes you go and you ask those questions.
No,
actually I,
I shouldn't say ask questions because that gives them a setup to provide you
with the answers and you already know the answers and you don't agree with them.
So instead of asking questions,
you take the reputation that you built is a bad ass and you raise points.
And when you raise points,
you have solutions and you have solutions that you've already socialized with
the team that you've already maybe even tested or you've at least tried.
In other words,
these are solutions that you know are going to work
and also pick your battles.
Pick your battles.
You got to,
you're going to have to eat some,
some stupid stuff.
You're going to do some lame things,
but you got to pick your battles.
You're not going to be able to change everything.
So you got to pick the most impactful issues to deal with.
And the other one's just,
you support those.
And you follow those like a good soldier
because that gives you more capital when you do raise issues and,
and here's the other piece.
When you raise issues up the chain of command,
and this is a piece that people mess this up all the time.
When you raised these points up the chain of command and when you give the
solutions,
you have to do it from a point of humility.
You can't be looking for the credit.
You can't be looking for the Atta boy.
You got to come across and you've got it not just come across.
You've got to actually be the humble person putting forth some suggestions on
how to do things better.
Anti that the,
the absolute black belt move is when you get them to think that it's their idea
and that came up with it and that Dave made up that solution.
That's the ultimate black belt move.
That's
what you're looking to achieve and that is how you win.
And that is what I did with my career.
I worked as hard as I could.
I followed everything they told me,
but when something stood out,
I was able to attack it,
address it,
and get the problem solved or changed because I had built up that capital.
So build your reputation,
build the relationships,
build and vet your idea and your solution,
and then present it with humility.
Next question is from a guy named Jonathan Mural,
how would his lifestyle of extreme discipline translate to someone living a
seemingly unrelated life,
artists,
writers,
et Cetera,
who might find more productivity in pockets of leisure or late at night?
Now,
I would argue that in these creative pursuits,
you actually require even more discipline,
and I would venture to guess that the biggest reason that creative types people
in creative industries,
they were,
the reason that they don't produce isn't because they don't have vision and it's
not because they don't have talent.
I can just about guarantee that in most cases it's a lack of discipline.
I,
I'm always saying about about working out.
I'm always saying that the,
the weights in the gym aren't going to lift themselves.
You've got to go lift them.
Well,
it's the same thing with a book.
That book isn't going to write itself.
You got to write it in.
The painting isn't going to paint itself.
You got to paint it,
and if you don't feel like writing or drawing or painting or composing,
that doesn't matter.
You do it anyways.
You grit down and you forced the words on to the paper or you force the brush
onto the paper or you force the notes out of the instrument.
That's what you have to do.
You have to make it happen.
You have to force yourself to do it
and it's not always going to be good and you might go back,
you might write a thousand words and you might delete 950 of them,
but you got 50 words,
50 words that you didn't have before,
50 words that you've created that are solid,
50 words closer to reaching your goal.
Now,
as far as the time of day goes,
to me,
it doesn't matter if,
if you have some kind of time of day where things seem to flow better or
whatever,
great.
Take advantage of it.
I think.
I think people think because I wake up early,
which I do that I believe that everyone must do that.
But honestly it's,
it's,
that's not true.
It's,
it's the principle.
it's about the principle,
not about the specific time.
And I've got to throw a big butt on that
because although you can,
you can maybe work at different times or maybe you stay up later or maybe do
better work at two o'clock in the morning or three o'clock in the morning.
And so there's no way you're getting up at four 30 that's okay.
But that doesn't mean oversleep.
And it doesn't mean procrastinated.
It doesn't mean hit the snooze button.
And it doesn't mean staying up late,
diving into the depths of useless youtube videos and claim that that is you
being creative.
Do not lie to yourself.
There's a decent chance that being creative is actually being lazy in your mind.
Do not,
do not fall into that.
Trap me and I'll tell you something else.
In order to gain skills,
in order to master your craft,
any craft you have to practice,
you have to practice and practice and practice.
Over and over and over again and again.
And that requires discipline,
that requires discipline.
And that is another example of how discipline will equal freedom.
The more you practice your craft,
the better you get at it,
the more freedom you have to create.
So build the structure and follow.
It's put the discipline into your life
and the discipline.
It will increase your skills and it will increase your productivity
and the discipline will,
it'll set you free.
Now going on to the next question here.
Will the muster event,
oh,
sorry,
this is from Marco Lopez,
Mario Lopez.
Will the muster event be a once a year thing?
Only after working with and training so many different companies,
are there any repeating patterns or common weaknesses that business owners seem
to need to work on?
And it also says,
will you please encourage Jocko to do nother Joe Rogan podcast?
So right on,
Joe.
Joe knows I'm standing by,
we'll,
we'll make it happen at some point.
Yeah,
great to be on his show.
We're just,
we're just now getting around around two,
two with,
with Tim.
So maybe Joe's around the corner.
So we'll,
we'll have to wait and see on that one.
All right.
To get to the question here,
for those of you don't know the extreme ownership muster as a leadership event
that we're having in in San Diego,
California,
I'm doing it with,
with my business partner,
the coauthor of the book,
extreme ownership,
Leif Babin,
who's,
uh,
a seal that
I worked with for many years and my brother,
and we're holding this thing in San Diego,
California on October 20th and 21st.
And what the event is,
it's going to be about combat leadership.
That's what it's going to be about.
It's gonna be about combat leadership and we're going to teach the fundamental
principles of combat leadership and how to apply them on the battlefield in
business and in life,
all,
all three.
And they're all,
you're going to see when you come,
you're going to see how all three of the applications are the same.
These fundamental combat leadership principles,
they don't change regardless of whether you're out hunting down bad guys or
whether you're hunting for a sale,
they don't change.
And their response to the event has been,
it's been awesome and we've got a ton of people come into it,
which likely means it looks like we're going to do another event.
Possibly we got to carve the time out of the schedule,
but it looks like possibly the spring of 2017 likely going to be somewhere on
the east coast.
If it's going to be somewhere on the east coast,
there's probably a pretty good chance.
Uh,
we'll be looking at New York City,
not set in stone that we're going to do it,
not set in stone when we're going to do it.
We might wait another year.
I don't know yet.
It's just up in the air.
We have so much stuff on our plates right now that we've got to figure out if we
can fit it in.
But if we do it again,
maybe we'll head out to the east coast and you know,
New York City get some.
Now the next part of this question is,
are there any repeating patterns or common weaknesses that business owners need
to work on?
And the answer is yes,
absolutely there are.
And we see the same issues from company to company and from leader to leader and
the same issues that we see in the civilian sector or the same issues that we
saw while we were working with seal platoons and training soup tunes and the
core problems that we see or what we wrote about in the book extreme ownership.
That's one of the reasons we wrote the book was because when we'd work with
these companies,
people would say,
do you have this stuff written down anywhere?
And eventually we wrote it down.
Now what are some of those issues that we run into me?
And you've got departments and divisions that aren't working together to cover
move.
You've got communications not being made in a simple,
clear,
concise manner.
You got either too much micromanagement which leaves the troops did take no
initiative or you've got not enough guidance and the troops now don't know which
direction to head into.
Or you get a company that's trying to take on too many projects are too many
initiatives at the same time and they don't prioritize and execute.
So they ended up getting none of them done.
And,
and then the obviously the most impactful one is when you have leaders and team
members taking ownership,
real ownership,
extreme ownership of everything in a world to make sure that problems get
uncovered and owned and resolved because if leaders and members of the team,
if they don't take ownership of the problems,
then guess who solves the problems?
Nobody.
So these are all,
again,
these are our fundamental problems that I saw when I was training seal platoons
and it's the same thing I see now is the same solutions that we apply to these
same problems.
Learning the tactics,
the fundamental tactics of leadership is is what we get down to
and we'll see at the muster.
All right,
next,
this next question is from Damien Hudson.
What does Jocko struggle with or maybe better to say,
what is he at work on?
He comes across bulletproof and just pushes through on everything.
Would like to know his method for identifying weaknesses and putting structures
in place to resolve,
correct,
improve,
would like to know his approach for his personal challenges?
Well,
first of all,
I can assure you that I am far from bulletproof.
And when you ask what I struggle with,
I struggle with everything.
I'm,
I'm not naturally gifted at pretty much anything.
I'm not naturally strong.
I'm not naturally fast though certainly not the,
uh,
the sharpest tool in the shed.
And so I constantly have to work on my weaknesses.
Andy,
if you want to know what my weaknesses are,
theirs,
we don't have enough time on the podcast to list all my weaknesses.
I mean it just,
that's the way it is now as far as my method for identifying weaknesses,
it's pretty simple.
I'm a constantly doing a self assessment and detaching and looking at what I'm
doing and what I can do better.
And I asked people that are close to me,
people that I trust,
ask them if they have any feedback for me,
ask them if anything I could do better or where I can improve.
So that's pretty simple.
Do a self assessment,
ask other people and find out what your weaknesses are and what you could do
better.
And then the next part of the question is,
what do I do to put structures in place to resolve correct and improve?
Well,
I,
I just attack those problems.
We weakness identified Roger attack the weakness problem identified Roger attack
the problem.
And I'll tell you,
I'm not a guy that spends a bunch of time over analyzing or overplanning or
diving deep into meditation on how I'm going to attack a problem.
I simply attack the problem.
Now,
that doesn't mean that I blindly attack and it doesn't mean that I hold a course
without checking on my progress.
As I attack a problem,
I'm going to continually assess and make sure that I'm on the right course,
that I'm,
that I'm headed in the right direction and,
and making sure that it's the most efficient path and I will absolutely change
course if I see something I can do better.
And because I have that kind of attitude,
it allows me to move quickly to execute and then initiate change and alter the
course as I go if it's needed.
And it's the same attitude that I had when I was in the seal teams.
I could be very decisive very quickly because the decisions themselves did not
close my mind.
The decisions did not close my mind.
I would make a decision and I would continue to reassess and readjust as needed,
but also as we moved forward towards a solution.
So you got a problem.
Step one,
identify the problem.
Step two,
attack it.
Step three,
reassess and adjust and keep attacking.
Get that thing solved.
Next question is from Chris Bell,
how to stay motivated when every day is a struggle to accomplish goals.
Well,
I can tell you very easily this is,
this isn't about motivation and accomplishing your goals is not about
motivation.
It's about discipline.
I already talked about that once a day and I'll say it again.
I probably talked about it more than you want us to talk to about it a bunch.
I talk about it all the time.
It is about discipline.
Motivation is fickle.
Motivation comes and go.
I mean,
you think about motivation.
You,
you is sympt something as simply as being hungry.
Can Sap your motivation,
right?
That's ridiculous.
You can't rely on that.
You have,
oh my blood sugar went down.
I'm,
I'm not motivated anymore.
Oh,
I didn't get enough caffeine.
I'm not motivated.
No wrong answer.
Motivation is unreliable.
And when you're counting on motivation to get your goals accomplished,
you're likely going to fall short.
So don't count on motivation.
Count on discipline.
You know what you have to do.
Go make yourself do it.
Make yourself do it.
Everybody wants it.
Some kind of magic pill or some life hacker,
something that eliminates the need to do the work.
Well,
I will tell you what you need to do the work.
You got to hold the line,
you got to make it happen yourself.
You have to make it happen.
It's not going to happen on its own.
So dig in,
find the discipline,
the discipline,
and accomplish the goals.
Period.
That's it.
And our next question is from Austin Farley and he said best advice to today's
active duty force regardless of branch about career oversight,
deployments,
differences between all sorts service members.
Okay.
So the basic question is best advice.
Well,
the advice
besides be aggressive and stay safe.
That's my number one.
Uh,
I would tell you for me the biggest component for success in the military in my
opinion,
is to do a great job in whatever you're doing.
And I know that sounds pretty obvious,
but I'll tell you,
I saw a lot of guys over the years,
we're always looking for the next ticket to punch or the next good deal or the
next job that they had to get to take to make a promotional or whatever.
And for me,
for the most part,
I just took what they gave me and I did the best I could at it.
And I'll tell you,
not only did this keep the navy happy cause the navy,
you know,
they had a trooper that was just getting after it.
It also kept me happy cause I wasn't sweating the promotion or the evaluations
or any of the political stuff.
I was just,
I wasn't getting after it to the best of my ability.
And if you do that,
I,
in my opinion,
if you do that,
your career will take care of itself.
You'll get the good jobs because people will want you in those good jobs.
And the other thing I would say is this
a big piece of being in the military?
Is it gut check?
This hard work?
It's either too hot or too cold.
It's not enough food.
It's not enough sleep.
It's not enough water.
It's hurry up and wait.
It's planned for months to do nothing and then don't plan at all to do something
for months.
And on top of all that,
you throw the politics and the egos and the bureaucracy,
and when you mix all that together,
it can be pretty miserable.
But I will tell you this,
all that misery,
relish,
relish every moment of it because those hard things,
those rough things,
those are a part of the experience of the military and it's experiences like
that.
I promise you will fall for some twisted reason.
You will miss them when you leave.
So don't hate them.
Don't avoid them.
Dive into them and kick them in the ass with a smile on your face.
Because another thing is that smile is contagious and you'll elevate the morale
of your whole unit
when you wear that smile.
So have fun and kick ass at what you're doing.
And for those of you out there on the front lines,
like I said,
to be aggressive,
the best way to mitigate risk on the battlefield is to be aggressive.
Do not be reactive.
Step up and get after it.
And by the way,
tall you active duty folks.
Thank you for what you're doing and for the vets that are listening.
Thank you for what you did.
Next up,
I got a question from
Paul wet kick and it says,
unfortunately,
this is to Tim,
I guess unfortunately you Rogan and Harris all pussyfooting around him.
I realize he's probably in an intimidating presence,
but ask him how he feels about killing people,
especially possibly innocence and don't let him use the doing my job bad guys,
collateral damage narratives.
Ask him how he feels about it.
He's intelligent enough to cope with being pressed for an authentic answer.
So Paul wants to know about killing people and possibly killing innocent people.
And what?
That's how I feel about that.
So first of all,
the nature of war is death.
The nature of war is,
is killing.
That is what war is.
And of course there's all kinds of other components to war.
There's economic and cultural and diplomatic and strategic.
But at its fundamental core wars about death and war is about killing.
And in the question here,
I'm told I'm not allowed to use the narrative of doing my job,
but there's a reason why that narrative exists because death and killing
actually is the job of a soldier.
And we train for that job and when the time comes,
we do our job and we are good with it.
Now part of that
comes from the training,
and part of that also comes from the dehumanization of the enemy.
Yes,
that is a true statement.
The enemy becomes dehumanized to the soldier.
That's one of the reasons why soldiers are generally okay with it.
And in the past,
the military had to help that process along.
They had to help the soldier dehumanize the enemy.
And it still does do that to some extent,
but I think in the wars that we are in now,
we don't need any help dehumanizing the enemy.
The enemy dehumanizes himself.
You see,
we in the military,
we witness what they do,
we see what they do,
we see the results of the torture and the rape and the murder.
We see families beheaded,
we see people skinned alive.
We see young people,
kids,
kids
forced to carry out suicide bombings.
And now
with the Internet inaction,
the whole world can see the completely despicable and brutal behavior of these
sub human savages,
burning people alive,
throwing people from buildings,
drowning people in cages,
10 year old sex slaves.
It's absolutely disgusting and abhorrent.
And I will tell you that I have no problem whatsoever killing all these vile
creatures,
all of them.
Now you also ask about killing innocents,
killing innocent people.
And as I already stated,
the nature of war is death
and in war innocent people sometimes are killed.
Then you,
you want to know how I feel about it?
Well,
it is horrible.
It is horrible.
It is awful when it does occur and yes,
it does occur.
They didn't let me tell you
that America goes through great lengths,
extreme lengths,
and in doing so incurs incredible risk to prevent killing innocent people on the
battlefield.
When I fought with the one one AED in the bowel Ramadi in 2006 the entire
strategy,
the entire strategy was developed to minimize not only the killing of innocent
people,
but also to minimize the amount of infrastructure that was destroyed.
So the buildings and the power and the water,
all of that.
And again,
American troops took incredible risks,
incredible risks to mitigate
the risks of civilians.
But war is messy,
war is confusing,
war is imperfect,
war is hell.
And despite all the efforts that we make,
despite all the good intentions and the precautions and the planning,
sometimes it isn't.
People are killed and it's horrible.
It's horrible from a family of the slain and it's horrible for the military man
that pulled the trigger or drop the bomb or through their grenade.
It's horrible for the mission because in places like Iraq and Afghanistan,
and we are there to protect the local populace.
So it takes us backwards strategically as we try to win the hearts and minds of
the people.
But you know what?
It doesn't defeat us.
It doesn't beat us.
And it doesn't even turn the local populace against us.
And I'm speaking now from my experience in the battle of Ramadi and let it be
perfectly clear that the local population in Ramadi absolutely wanted us there.
They wanted us on the ground in their neighborhoods.
They wanted us to help them get rid of the insurgents that were terrorizing
them,
literally terrorizing them.
And when innocent people were killed,
for whatever reason,
we apologized and we did what we could to help.
And we met and we broke bread and we explained what had gone wrong and we asked
what we could do to help and we paid the money and we help them repair their
buildings.
We did whatever we could,
and I will tell you in this never gets represented in the press,
but most of the time the local populace,
they understood,
they understood it was a war.
They understood it was a war against evil and they understood that that meant
violence
and they understood that in our efforts to help them get rid of the cancer that
ravage their city.
Well,
they understood
that there would be bloodshed in removing that cancer.
War is hell.
It is best to be avoided at all costs so that innocent lives are not lost,
but
sometimes war cannot be avoided and sometimes war should not be avoided
sometimes in order to protect the innocence.
War is the only choice
and I am thankful
that there are men and women in the military that have the courage and the
strength and the moral fortitude to stand up and face evil and to also withstand
the awful burden
of killing they end of death.
Now I think this is the last question here.
This question came from and Vasily.
It says,
what are the biggest lessons learned from Jujitsu that transcend the art of
fighting itself?
And can be applied to being an effective leader.
So
I'm a practitioner of Jujitsu and it is a pretty incredible,
it's a pretty incredible thing to train.
And for those either train Jujitsu,
you know what I'm talking about.
For those of you that don't train Jujitsu,
go train Jujitsu
cause there's so much to be learned from Jujitsu about leadership and about
life.
I mean,
for instance,
I talked about discipline a lot today in Jujitsu,
you're going to learn about discipline because it takes discipline to get on the
mat day after day,
week after week,
month after month,
a year after year.
And you won't always feel like training.
As Fun as Jujitsu is,
there's gonna be days you don't feel like training.
But you have to find the discipline and you have to do it.
So you're going to learn about discipline.
In Jujitsu,
you're also going to learn about humility because in Jujitsu you will get
humbled.
You will get beat by people that are smaller than you and weaker than you,
and they will smash you.
They will literally submit you.
And that is humbling and there is no escaping it.
And those,
those are very important because like I said,
I've said this before is that those are lessons that some traditional martial
arts would try and teach you almost as theoretical lessons.
You know,
like you,
you must be disciplined,
they'll tell you that in theory.
But in Jujitsu,
like I said,
without,
without discipline,
there's no,
there's no progress.
And in a traditional martial art they'll say,
oh,
you know,
you must be humble.
But like I said,
and Jujitsu you actually get humbled.
So jujitsu teaches you a lot about life
and that's one of the things that make it,
it's so powerful.
And it as the question back to the question was,
what does it teach you about leadership at?
Absolutely teaches you some key things about leadership.
And I'll give you a couple of the most important elements.
First of all,
and detachment,
and I've mentioned this word a couple of times today and Jujitsu,
I'll tell you right now,
if you let your star self start to get frustrated or you let yourself start to
get angry or just emotional in general,
you will start to make bad decisions.
And when you start to make bad decisions,
that is the beginning of the end.
So you have to be able to detach from that emotion,
that frustration,
and you've got to focus on doing the right thing at the right time.
It's absolutely necessary.
And,
and that's the same thing in a combat leadership position or in any leadership
situation,
you cannot get caught up in all the chaos and all the mayhem.
You can't let your emotions get ahold of you.
So you have to be able to detach from that.
You have to be able to step back and breathe and see the full picture of what is
happening without the cloud of emotion and all of that mayhem obscuring your
vision so that you can make good decisions.
And Jujitsu,
we'll teach you to do that.
Now,
another piece,
Jujitsu that transfers directly into,
into leadership is the idea of indirect warfare,
right?
So when Jujitsu,
the whole premise is to attack the weaknesses of your opponent.
You don't want tack their strengths,
you want to attack it.
I mean,
just fundamentally you,
you attack the weak areas of their body,
like the joints or the neck.
You're,
you're not attacking the strongest parts of their body.
And if you attack where your opponent is strong.
So if you have a opponent that's very good at defending one type of one position
or one type of hold,
you're just going to wear yourself out as if you're attacking that.
And eventually you're gonna run out of energy and then they're going to get the
advantage.
So you can't just attack the strengths,
you have to attack the weak points in Jujitsu.
And how on top of that,
you also have to distract your opponent
and you have to make them defend some area.
So you might maybe attack one area so that they put their defenses there,
but it's just a faint,
because what you're really gonna do is you're gonna go and attack and area
whether or not defending you're going to attack their weak areas.
And it's the same thing with leadership.
And the clearest example of where this is directly seen in leadership is when
you're dealing with people's key goes.
So you take a person that has a big strong ego,
you don't attack that ego head on that we'll just make that person get ultra
defensive.
Or if you attack their ego,
they're going to get defensive immediately.
Now you've built up,
now you're gonna have an even harder fight.
So what you do is you bypass the regal.
Maybe you even massage their ego a little bit
so that they let down their guard
so that they let you into their head a little bit.
And then tactically and quietly,
you sneak in and you plant the seeds of what you're trying to get them to do,
of where you're trying to lead them.
And soon enough without seeing it,
those seeds are going to grow.
And your idea and your plan and your leadership comes to fruition.
And that is indirect warfare.
And it's the same thing in Jujitsu.
It's the same thing in business and it's actually the same thing on the
battlefield as well.
We don't attack enemy strengths unless it cannot be avoided.
So take up that Jujitsu,
start training,
and apply those lessons across the board in your life.
And I think that's,
I think that's it for questions for now.
Uh,
thanks to everybody for listening and thanks of course to Mister Mister Tim
Ferris for having me on.
Tim has been for those of you don't know,
he's been a huge supporter since I met him and I really appreciate Tim.
Everything you done for me and everything that's kind of stemmed from that has
been,
has been awesome.
The interaction from everybody through social media and Twitter and Facebook and
all that and everyone that's listening and giving me feedback on,
on the podcasts that I have and the book,
uh,
that,
that I wrote with my buddy Lafe and it's just awesome to connect with so many
people and it's awesome to know that there's so many people that are in the
game.
So many people that want to get after it,
dislike me,
looking to get better,
looking to do better,
look in a be better.
So thanks to everybody for everything.
And like I said,
especially thanks to Tim for,
uh,
for kicking this whole thing off.
So until next time,
this is Jocko
out.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
Here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account,
for instance.
Now.
Normally when I have a sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of SCC regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by wealth front that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim,
it's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
This episode is brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the people I have interviewed,
world class performers across the military,
entertainment,
sports,
and beyond all have some type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help you.
This change comes through guided meditation and headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple,
so what I recommend is that you take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of scientific studies and try it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the founder,
Andy Puddicombe,
a ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is P.
Uddi,
c.
O.
M.
E,
if you want to look that up,
but otherwise download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation,
completely free,
10 minutes a day.
That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just go to headspace.com forward slash temp.